vous voyez la photo de famille de ce
nouveau premier conseil des ministres de
fait les pillards et parmi ce groupe il
ya le nouveau ministre des finances
carlos letton vous allé m'excuser la
prononciation lettons ont dit l'état au
centre à lomé pour le vrai lait dans les
temps des temps nouveaux mines et des
finances je le disais vous êtes un
économiste connu dans les milieux
économiques vous que vous connaissent
bien le grand public vous connaît
beaucoup moins de bois elle vous nerveux
un peuple ce n'est pas rien bon c'est
pas rien évidemment nerveux je trouve
trop agitée pour être nerveux évidemment
cc c'est une journée spéciale pour moi
écouter ya à peu près 40 ans je suis
arrivé dans ce pays avec une valise
pleine d'espoirs et de rêves et me voilà
quarante ans plus tard ministres
finances c'est quand même quelque chose
alors oui c'est une journée très réussie
a fait plus on le comprend très bien
par contre monsieur couillard le premier
ministre a mis la table pour un contexte
extrêmement difficile il a dit aux
québécois aujourd'hui et peut-être plus
clairement qu'en campagne électorale
encore les décisions difficiles sont à
venir
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que nous avons un déficit et donc que
nos dépenses sont systématiquement plus
élevé que nos revenus
l'économie du québec n'est pas en
récession croissance lente mais on n'est
pas en récession et on n'arrive pas à
boucler le budget donc il ya un déficit
structurel il va falloir régler ça
comment évidemment donnez-moi quelques
joueurs je viens pas encore rencontré
les mais mais mais mais mais mes
collègues de mes services financiers qui
voit un briefing book épais comme ça
mais en fin de compte il ya deux choses
les revenus et les dépenses
nous pensons que du côté des revenus il
faut accélérer la croissance économique
pour pouvoir espérer avoir un peu plus
de revenus mais ce qui est
particulièrement inquiétant c'est que du
côté des dépenses
là il ya des défis importants à relever
est-ce que vous allez devoir peut-être
remettre en question certains
engagements nous avait pris lors de la
campagne électorale
je pense notamment aux frais de garderie
vous voulez pas augmenté aussi
rapidement
je pense à l'élimination de la taxe
santé est-ce que vous allez être obligés
comme le gouvernement à faire dire on
n'est pas capable de faire ça non non
non engagement on va on va les tenir on
va faire exactement ce qu'on avait dit
qu'on allait faire puisque la taxe santé
spécifiquement on avait dit qu'on
commencerait la réduire une fois le
l'équilibré budgétaire atteint donc on
va d'abord équilibrer le budget et puis
après quand on va dégager des surplus
l'année 3 4 5 que quoi que ce soit alors
à ce moment là oui on va commencer par
réduire et éliminer la taxe santé
on n'est pas dans un contexte de baisses
d'impôts pour votre premier budget qui
doit être déposé dans quelques semaines
ça va être assez rapide comme budget
généralement il y a quelques mois pour
faire un budget nous on va voir si cette
semaine donc il faut le faire rapidement
mais le budget du mois de février n'a
pas été votée donc au québec a pas de
budget aujourd'hui donc il va falloir le
faire ça il faut que ça se fasse
rapidement mais en même temps il faut
que ce soit un budget crédible il faut
que ce soit un budget qui rétablit la
confiance de la population et la
confiance des investisseurs n'est pas de
baisses d'impôts non non ça y est on a
balade dans les bois de rose non plus
est-ce que vous êtes prêts considérés de
reporter la cible du dif 7-0 par exemple
où c'est une religion la cible de 2,0
c'est pas une religion c'est une
obligation
il faut équilibrer nos j'arrive
maintenant d'entre elle sait pas encore
quel est l'état réel des choses
vous aviez dit du budget puis on les
gens du parfait bricoleur beaucoup à
publiciser vous aviez dit du dernier
budget de l'ue au maroc c'est un budget
sommes toutes là ses responsables donc
votre budget pourrait ressembler à celui
de monsieur marceau d'une certaine façon
mais ce qu'on ne savait pas
en février par exemple c'est que le
détail des dépenses de crédit n'avaient
pas été déposés dont on connaissait pas
un février qu'il était le vrai état des
dépenses de l'état et donc c'est là
qu'on va voir exactement l'état des
choses dans les prochaines semaines et
c'est là aussi le vérificateur général
qui avait regardé le côté des revenus
mais il n'avait pas non plus tous les
détails pour les dépenses il va aussi de
regarder en vain qu'on dépose un budget
donc pour pour aller chercher des
revenus à court terme des pourparlers
avec la fonction publique qu'est ce que
c'est sur la table a dit revoir les
conditions de travail des employés de
l'état revoir ce que les médecins obtenu
ça c'est sous la table oui on va et on
va essayer comme le gouvernement
précédent d'étaler ça il va falloir le
négocier vous avez demandé à votre
collègue la sarthe est évidemment savoir
parce personne oui c'est clair aussi les
conditions de travail
ce qui concerne le nombre de personnes
qui travaillent pour le gouvernement
est-ce qu'on va remplacer tous les
personnes qui vont prendre la retraite
par exemple tout ces détails là on va on
va les regarder mais encore une fois on
va surtout s'attarder
du côté des dépenses des dépenses de
programmes dépenses de fonctionnement
qui sont nettement plus élevés que les
revenus et donc il faut équilibrer sa
alors des moments effectivement
difficile un passage difficile
oui mais comme le premier ministre a
mentionné il faut qu'on soit réaliste
nous avons encore mark toner nous ne
sommes pas comme nos cousins européens
nous avons encore la capacité d'agir de
nous mêmes sans que des choses nous soit
imposée mais il faut qu'on le fasse
difficulté est-ce que vous devrez aller
rassurer les marchés est ce que ça fait
partie de vos tâches rapidement mais
granger oui quand j'ai dit qu'il nous
faut un budget crédible il faut que
justement que les marchés puissent
croire à ce budget monsieur l'état merci
beaucoup merci on va se reparler alors
bonne chance dans votre tâche de mines
et des finances merci vous pas manquer
de travail au cours des sept prochaines
semaines merci revenu sur notre plateau